on essayait n'essayez pas d'influencer
le vote par des applaudissements
intempestifs temps sûrement alors
maintenant c'est une chanson c'est une
chanson typiquement espagnols sont
typiquement espagnol chanson qui a été
inspiré par le folklore andalou le plus
pur c'est une chanson qui a pour titre
escarbilles rouler
pour mettre dans l'ambiance j'ai ouvert
mon strip tease espagnol vous à l'heure
une merveille ce fait pour garder bien
rim et le beau temps
seconde de button seconde de button et
les brawn ans
par les olé
voilà attendait l'ag de l'ordre tuez
vous faire profiter de toute la richesse
alors voici l'histoire du célèbre
toréador temps d'abord je vais me
préparer parce que vous savez que les
gitans ont un visage toujours très très
très tourmentée et ceci grâce à la
longueur de leurs cheveux si si c'est
alors qu'ils ont toujours comme ça en
vrai d'ailleurs je vais me leny escudero
et marsanne on m'appelle le beatle dit
pauvre primairement élimination de la
pellicule
et qu'un million bonbons
nous les bouées ou mais ouais mais on
est tous pas de calais thomas werlet 30
à la famille
hier qu'un million de bons mots version
française
c'était un grand torero d'espagne qui
n'avait jamais eu qu'un d'auron la
charmante aux revenus de certains qu'un
gentil toro doux comme un agneau
pourtant malgré maintenant de patients
nos rires on pouvait mais tu es la foule
à chaque fois lui faisant confiance se
disait cette fois et ce cadeau était mis
sous les yeux des passants dans l'arène
et jusqu'à 1000 francs et sa famille ont
pro sans se perdre dans les détails ce
métier tout rendre et comme ils savaient
pas écarté del toro il évitait la foule
criait d'aspiration toro s'est levé sous
l'ovation escarmouches
c'était le roi de la corrida n'en
n'oublie pas bien ces gobelets et un
million mort
m
les fous et gong
un version française
l'andalousie à la cerdagne chacun veut y
voir escape to par tout le public des
villes et campagnes et applaudi le grand
torero simon casas en fait à madrid une
grande euphorie d'un grand escamillo
suis dans l'arène taureau furieux vidéo
comme ça incompétent perdre allaient
tous se tournent à rennes
gentile toros empli de façon les
chaussettes sales ou puis par une lente
ascension à s'essayer encore
d'influencer le jury même fâché quand il
arrivait au caleçon vers la fin ça
devient un petit peu olé olé quand ils
arrivent au caleçon les femmes crièrent
d'applications enlever le à laver le
hâle est permis d'y réguler le navet le
mélange pas le tolérer le ko s camille
qui est bon et ses amis ce bureau de la
corrida dans toute l'espagne